aber in Kiew Berufs sich meine Kollegin
Christiane Hoffmann Frau Hoffmann eine
Überraschungsbesuch war das ohne Zweifel
Joe Biden dort in Kiew mitten in der
Innenstadt was wissen Sie über die
Hintergründe wie ist das vorbereitet
worden
der Besuch sollte natürlich viel
Symbolkraft haben gerade um diesen
Jahrestag herum und die Vorbereitung
lief so hören wir über Monate im
Geheimen in kleinem Kreis im Weißen Haus
in den zugehörigen Behörden und
natürlich hier auch in der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt und dann war es letzte Nacht
dass US-Präsident beiden nach Polen flog
und dann zehn Stunden sich in den Zug
gesetzt hat dass er hier in der Ukraine
keine
Passagierflüge gibt und er landete dann
heute morgen sehr früh in der in Kiel
und über die sozialen Medien wurden hier
Bilder geteilt dass eine Autokolonne
durch abgesperrte Straßen vor teilweise
so heißt das war auch das Telefon Netz
gestört in der unmittelbaren Umgebung
des Präsidenten Palastes das heißt
dieses Treffen fand quasi im Geheimen
Stadt und die Öffentlichkeit hat auch es
dann von erfahren als der Präsident
schon wieder aus der Hauptstadt
weggefahren war wie haben denn die
Ukraine so weit sie mit ihnen sprechen
konnten darauf reagiert zwar war das
Erleichterung Freude oder war da mehr
dahinter
ich glaube die Ukraine sind schon sehr
erleichtert und freuen sich auch dass
der US-Präsident diesen symbolischen
Besuch hier zum Jahrestag dieses
angriffskriegs von Russland auf die
Ukraine unternimmt und eben sich zehn
Stunden in den Zug setzt das wird
sicherlich hier in der Hauptstadt oder
im ganzen Land auch gesehen und man
fühlt sich dann Nähe dem Westen und
fühlt die Unterstützung hier im Land
auch wenn natürlich die Entbehrungen
dieses Krieges mittlerweile jede Familie
in der Ukraine spürth nun hatte bei mir
nicht nur Symbole dabei bei diesem
Besuch sondern auch handfeste Zusagen
eine halbe Milliarde US-Dollar an
Unterstützung weitere Waffenlieferungen
macht es ein signifikanten Unterschied
ja es ist eine halbe Milliarde Dollar
Unterstützung die er heute bekannt
gegeben hat
die USA haben bisher 50 Milliarden
geliefert gleichzeitig sind diese
umfassend umfasst diese halbe Milliarde
vor allem Granaten für Panzerhaubitzen
Luftabwehr Radar luftüberwachungs Radar
Entschuldigung und Luftabwehrraketen das
heißt das sind ähm Waffen und
Waffensysteme die jetzt schon die
Ukraine sehr stark benötigt und auch
jetzt schon hat es wird weiterhin
geliefert aber wo wo wo wo rum
präsidente Lenski hier seit einigen
Wochen vor allem bittet sind
Kampfflugzeuge und die um hier eine
wesentlichen Unterschied in diesem Krieg
zu erreichen und die Lehnen bisher die
USA und auch alle anderen eine
Verbündeten ab lassen Sie uns noch einen
Blick werfen auf den Gastgeber obwohl
oder mehr als letztes Jahr absolviert ja
ein Mammutprogramm in den letzten Tagen
wieder am Jahreszeit Diskussion auch ein
virtuelle Zuschaltung zu einem G7
Gipfeltreffen geben
selensky ist seit dem Kriegsbeginn von
vor fast einem Jahr so präsent wirkt
jetzt ein wenig müde ist das es ist das
ein Zeichen ist es so dass er da im
Grunde genommen auch das widerspiegelt
wie die Ukrainer sich fühlen nach diesen
vielen vielen schlimmen Monaten
er wirkt angespannt das glaube ich auf
jeden Fall ob er müde wirkt das kann ich
nicht beurteilen tatsächlich ist es so
dass seit einem Jahr ja das Land in
einem Krieg sich befindet und ähm Putin
die Existenz der Ukraine in Zweifel
zieht und negiert und wir hören eben aus
den Kampfgebieten in der Ostukraine dass
es sich dass da Moment Russland in dem
im Angriff ist und die die mehr Land
gewinnt und dass dadurch die Situation
für die ukrainische Armee viel
schwieriger geworden ist und für die
nächsten Tage erwartet man auch eine
massive Angriffswelle das heißt diese
Offensive die die Russen seit einiger
Zeit schon
anstrengen jetzt im beginnenden früher
die wird jetzt viel stärker laufen und
eben auch rund um diesen Jahrestag
erwartet man eine große Angriffswelle
eben nicht nur in diesem Osten der
Ukraine sondern in allen Landesteilen
also Anspannung seit einem Jahr die
jetzt auch noch schon mehrwegs
Christiane Hoffmann herzlichen Dank für
die Eindrücke für die Schilderung nach
Kiel heute Abend